we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 David P here's a caller who's
glad we were banned from tick tock
I'm glad you were banned from from tick
tock
because you're right you're in low life
oh well that's really sad I think the
caller will be saddened to hear
that we are back on Tick Tock so last
week I talked about being banned from
Tick Tock which is increasingly a great
platform for us to be reaching young
people young voters
here's how it all went down over the
weekend
we were originally banned from Tick Tock
for covet and election disinformation
okay we appealed it we were then told no
you're going to continue being banned
for violating the nudity policy now I
can assure you
we did not post any nudity I didn't post
nude pictures of myself there were no
nude pictures of trump posted there was
no nudity on our account whatsoever we
again appealed that and hundreds of you
rode into Tick Tock legal which I very
much appreciate without explanation
the account was reinstated we don't know
why days later
Tick Tock responded and said we've
reversed the decision
your account has been reinstated we
still know very little about what
happened but much to this caller's
dismay we are back on Tick Tock we have
a great bonus show for you today Kanye
West is apparently in talks to buy the
social media platform parlor I know you
probably forgot about parlor we will
talk about it a court has rejected an
appeal to give Americans Samoans U.S
citizenship we will talk about the basis
for that decision and lastly more and
more American companies are charging
employees for job training if they quit
before a certain amount of time has gone
by is it legal yeah it appears to be as
long as it's done in a certain way
is it ethical well that's a different
question all of those stories and more
on today's bonus show sign up at
joinpakman.com